à la forteresse royale de chinon ses
jeunes visiteurs ne viennent pas
découvrir l'histoire du château mais
plutôt participer à un atelier cuisine
voici julie l'animatrice
elle explique que la recette du jour est
très ancienne puisqu'elle date de
l'époque médiévale l'époque à laquelle
cette forteresse était encore habité et
qui s'appelle les gâteaux de la joie ces
enfants sont ravis
au menu de leurs vacances la préparation
d'un petit gâteau et là tu prépares quoi
des des petits sablés ils sont
particuliers ces petits sablés oui parce
qu'il est d'abord ils sont faits avant
il ya de la farine du sel du sucre
ap des pis une recette facile à préparer
un moment de partage agréable entre ses
enfants et leur animatrice
j'ai pas beaucoup de choses à aller
chercher dans déjà un vécu une
expérience et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup
d'enfants qui cuisinent à la maison et
par contre c'est une recette originale
qui n'ont jamais fait donc c'est aussi
une découverte pour eux avec d'autres
ingrédients et il se met facilement à
vouloir faire de jolis sable est quelque
chose de bon non seulement pour eux mais
aussi pour pouvoir offrir
léonie 11 ans participe elle aussi à
l'atelier
mais la fillette n'apprécie pas tous les
ingrédients se sont
pour ceux qu'ils aiment beaucoup les
épices oui ça sent bon moi je n'aime pas
trop les épices du pôle amplement mais
oui donc tu vas pas le manger
si par ces mots forcément que j'ai mangé
c'est fait pour léonie à raison
d'ailleurs l'atelier touche à sa fin il
est temps de mettre les sablés au four
avant de les déguster en famille